في أي يوم من الأيام في الولايات المتحدة، تقوم
شركات الطيران بتشغيل
45000 رحلة جوية تجارية تقلع
وتهبط وتسير في بعض
المطارات الأكثر ازدحامًا في العالم، حيث تنقل
ملايين الركاب بدقة
وأمان، ويمكن أن يكون ذلك بمثابة رقصة دقيقة
يمكن لخطأ واحد أن يوقف كل شيء.
كانت عمليات التوغل موجودة منذ أن
كان لدينا أكثر من
محقق سابق في NTSB في Runway، يتذكر بيل إنجليش
كارثة تينيريفي عام 1977، حيث اصطدمت طائرتان من طراز Boeing
747 ببعضهما البعض على
المدرج، مما أدى إلى مقتل أكثر من 500 شخص،
وكانت عمليات التوغل في المدرج صعبة للغاية
لعقود من الزمن
التقينا أنا والطيارين ومدربي الطيران في
مدرسة الطيران مغامرات الطيران في
فيرجينيا هنا يتم تعليم الطلاب الطيارين
حول غارات المدرج على
الفور تقريبًا في تدريبهم في
المقعد التجريبي لمدرب Twin Star الماسي،
بيل وأنا ننطلق في عرض
توضيحي لـ  ما يحدث في عملية
التوغل على المدرج وما الذي يمنع الطيارين من
ارتكاب أخطاء يمكن أن تكون مميتة،
هناك الكثير من الطبقات المضمنة هنا،
والكثير من وسائل الحماية لمنعها حتى
عندما يحدث خطأ ما من أن
يصبح كارثيًا،
خمس كاميرات تتدحرج لإظهار بعض
الحلول  بسيطة مثل العلامات الموجودة على
الممرات التي تؤدي إلى مدارج الطائرات،
الخط الأصفر القصير يذكر الطيارين بعدم
دخول المدرج، وهو عبارة عن كأس مقدس من الطلاء
تتطابق مع عبارات حاسمة بين
الطيارين ومراقبة الحركة الجوية،
يفتقر هذا المطار التنفيذي في ليسبورغ إلى بعض
التكنولوجيا التي
تنشر إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية (FAA) في المطارات الأكثر ازدحامًا
أضواء تحذيرية على مستوى البلاد مدمجة في أرصفة
الممرات والممرات، وحتى الرادار الجديد
الذي يمكنه تتبع الطائرات والمركبات الأخرى
على الأرض بقوة تصل إلى 50 بالمائة. لقد
حصلت على المطار بالداخل ونحن
ننتقل إلى الهبوط في دوغلاس
المطار الدولي هو أحد
أكثر مناطق العاصمة ازدحامًا وله أربعة مدارج، ثلاثة
منها متوازية مع بعضها البعض على الرغم
من أننا نهبط في طقس صافٍ، وقد
اتصل بيل بجهاز راديو يستخدم
لضعف الرؤية، هبوط لتوجيهنا إلى
المدرج المناسب الذي أقترب منه
المطار هنا، ومع مرور الوقت،
قمنا بتحرير بعض المنعطفات التي
وجهتها مراقبة الحركة الجوية لمحاذاة
المدرج، لقد تم السماح لي بالاقتراب
والآن تم
السماح لي بالهبوط
[تصفيق]  إن
التحول بالضبط إلى المكان الذي
تخبرك به وحدات التحكم على الأرض لا يقل
أهمية عن الأوامر المعطاة
في الجو. يشير لي بيل إلى كيفية
استخدامه لتطبيق iPad لتتبع مكان
تواجدنا على أرض المطار،
المهم هو أن تكون على دراية بمكان
تواجدك.  المطار، خاصة في
مطار مزدحم مثل دالاس، هذا أمر
بالغ الأهمية لأننا ننظر إلى ما
نحن فيه هنا، فلدينا
طائرات قادمة من اه
المحطة هناك في كلا الاتجاهين اه
طوال الوقت كما تعلم في مطار مثل
هذا هناك  هي عدة
مدارج مختلفة تتماشى مع بعضها البعض بشكل صحيح
ولكني أشعر أن الأمر يصبح أكثر
خطورة في المطار عندما
تتقاطع مدارجه، نعم بالضبط عندما
تنشر الأخبار مثل توغلات المدرج
وعليك أن تكون
أكثر يقظة تقريبًا أثناء الطيران.  تعني
بيئة المدرج خاصة في
مطار مثل هذا، يجب عليك بالتأكيد أن
تكون أكثر يقظة، وكما تعلم بما
رأيناه مؤخرًا، أعتقد أن الجميع مستيقظين وقد
وضعوا رؤوسهم على الدوران الآن، نعم
نحن الآن نسير بسيارات الأجرة للإقلاع من
مدرج مختلف  في Dallas Runway 3-0
الذي يعبر أمام
مدارج الشمال التي اعتدنا عليها للتو، تخبرنا مراقبة الحركة الجوية البرية
بالإقلاع مع
اقتراب الرحلة من تلك المدارج من
الجنوب،
وعادةً ما تكون رحلتي العادية من
مطار بلد أصغر، وهو ليس مزدحمًا
ولا يوجد برج لمراقبة الحركة الجوية.
ما هو واضح من هذا العرض هو
أن طبيعة هذه الحوادث
لم تتغير ولكنها سلطت
الضوء على السلامة. أعتقد أن التعامل مع
المشكلات هو ما نقوم به في
مجال الطيران، ونحن نحاول بناء تلك القوة
النظام الذي تكون فيه السلامة أمرًا بالغ الأهمية، حسنًا، عند
النزول، أمسكه هناك، فقط أمسكه
هناك، لقد تعلقت به تمامًا
في المرة الثانية التي حصلت عليها